accor pc ps pour les municipales mais
pas encore de liste commune publiée
georges marchais notre invité dans ce
journal série d'arrestations de membres
de l' eta notamment à bayonne pour l'un
des dirigeants de l'organisation
terroriste bat
oui à superphénix le surgénérateur va
redémarrer une fuite avait été constaté
il ya 20 mois sur le directeur la
passion aux jeux olympiques en 92
albertville les jeux olympiques seront
retransmis par antenne 2 et fr3 ronald
regan fait ses adieux les gestes du
président il copié les gestes de
l'acteur un étonnant documents à la fin
de ce genre bonsoir
et pour commencer cette histoire qui
nous ferait croire au miracle
des survivants ont été retrouvés à
lénine à cannes en arménie la ville qui
avait été complètement démolies par le
tremblement de terre du 7 décembre
trente cinq jours après oui trente cinq
jours six hommes sont sortis de la nuit
rémy rosh ha et casa copions 50 ans il
vient passer 35 jours sous les décombres
de son immeuble prisonniers en compagnie
de cinq autres hommes le 7 décembre et
les casses de mandat cinq voisins de
l'aider à remonter de la cave de lourdes
jarre juste à ce moment nous avons
entendu un grondement terrible c'est
penser qu'une guerre avait éclaté
raconte-t-il
les murs et le plafond tremble s'effrite
mais la cave résistent ils sont sains et
saufs
bloqué dans le noir par chance la cave
est plein de provisions des concerts des
légumes et des jus de fruits qu'ils vont
consommer avec une économie à et case
possède en plus quelques rudiments de
médecine et il soigne ses camarades un
véritable miracle en tout cas une
histoire incroyable car c'est sous un
immeuble de huit étages réduit un gros
tas de gravats que les six hommes ont
survécu
jamais ils l'ont perdu le moral pas un
instant distille nous avons douté d'être
un jour découvert libéré
la très gros coup de filet dans les
milieux terroristes basques ira bayonne
et à poitiers dix personnes ont été
arrêtées parmi elles l'un des hauts
responsables de letea peut-être l'un des
tout premiers dirigeants cela montre en
tout cas la détermination de la police
française à vouloir décapiter le terrain
et cela en collaboration avec les
espagnols tout de suite les faits hervé
brusini philippe etcheverry des
policiers espagnols et français sont la
tête baissée au chou ternera va subir
ses premiers interrogatoires
rompu aux techniques de la clandestinité
il s'est rasé la barbe mais pour celui
qui se nomme en réalité hourticot etxea
ça n'a pas suffi depuis un mois une
armada de véhicules banalisés surveiller
ses allées et venus tout spécialement
autour de cette maison
hier soir les renseignements généraux du
commissaire bardon ont tendu leurs
pièges dernière à et une amie sorte de
la ville avec cette moto les policiers
simultanée accident ici même armé d'une
grenade et d'un automatique 9 mm
dernières attentes de s'enfuir tire un
coup de feu
finalement il est ceinture est l'un des
tout premiers responsables de thé est
militaire vient d'être arrêté il s'était
exilé en france depuis les années 70
membres du comité exécutif de
l'organisation séparatiste son
interpellation représente un rude coup
pour eta mais les spécialistes le savent
malgré la mort de txomin le chef
historique l'arrestation de chant ty
potro 187 et séparatistes ont toujours
su se donner de nouveaux chefs
d'ailleurs la direction de
l'organisation et collégial une
vingtaine de membres selon la police
espagnole à madrid c'est la satisfaction
le chef du gouvernement felipe gonzalez
a qualifié d'importante l'arrestation de
ternir à ternir à dans l'extradition
devrait être demandé dans les prochaines
heures
la politique le ps et le pc se sont mis
d'accord cette après midi il y avait un
sommet rue de solférino au siège du ps
donc entre les deux numéros un de chaque
partie pierre mauroy et georges marchais
pas de liste publiée en perspective des
municipales mais un mot d'ordre
s'opposer aux initiatives de la droite
pour revenir au pouvoir
roland sicard
il est des regards qui ne trompent pas
socialistes et communistes part et c'est
irréconciliables après les passes
d'armes de la dernière session
parlementaire
les voici de nouveau ensemble mais pour
un accord de raison une gauche à lens en
ordre dispersé à la bataille des
municipales n'aurait fait la faire ni du
ps ni du pc
résultat une déclaration commune aux
deux parties la première depuis six ans
mais aussi un échange d'amabilités qui
montre que la discussion a été rude nous
voyions mais je vais répondre à georges
marchais qu heureusement qu'on a voulu
un accord national ça facilite les
choses
certaine façon un corps difficile mais
accord tout de même et dans la sphère
chacun a dû faire des concessions
les communistes ne mèneront pas leurs
voix à celles de la droite à l'assemblée
nationale le gouvernement de michel
rocard peut donc être tranquille le ps
de son côté modère ses ambitions le pc
devrait conserver la tête de liste dans
la plupart des communes où le maire
sortant et communistes des décisions qui
reste maintenant à appliquer à la base
ville par ville
ce ne sera sans doute pas le plus facile
alors voilà donc ce qui s'est passé cet
après midi rue de solférino au siège du
ps avec nous ce soir georges marchais
bonsoir monsieur marché bonsoir
alors cela fait six ans qu'on n'avait
pas vu un tel sommet entre le pc et le
ps
alors donc pour les mici pour les
municipales il y aura des listes de
rassemblement de la gauche
est ce que monsieur marché c'est l'union
de la gauche que vous formez avec le ps
ah c'est la reconduction effectivement
de l'accord qui avait été conclu en 1983
c'est à dire que communistes socialistes
radicaux et autres forces de progrès
vont se rassembler sur des listes
d'union de la gauche avec à double
objectif d'une part conserver les
mairies que nous gérons ensemble avec le
maire communiste quand il est communiste
avec le maire socialiste quand il est
socialiste avec le radical de gauche
quand il est radical de gauche et
essayer ensemble de gagner d'autres
municipalité sur la droite
par conséquent cet accord ouvre des
possibilités
georges marchais j'imagine que vous vous
sentez lié par cet accord politique
qu'est ce que cela signifie par exemple
que vous allez vous abstenir de
critiquer le gouvernement
dans les deux mois qui viennent écouter
l'accord et la déclaration commune elle
est très clair nous ne portons pas la
même appréciation sur la politique
gouvernementale et nous continuerons
chaque fois que nous considérons que la
politique menée par le gouvernement
départ conforme aux intérêts de la
population nous le diront et mêmes vous
pourriez continuer à soutenir des grèves
par exemple dans les étages et ses voies
finir mêmes
nous combattrons effectivement cette
politique
cela étant dit nous affirmons très
clairement que notre adversaire c'est la
droite
nous combattons la droite et d'ailleurs
nous n'avons cessé de le faire
enfin nous avons appelé à voter françois
mitterrand pour bat chirac
nous avons appelé à voter pour des
députés socialistes qui était arrivé
avant le communiste pour battre la
droite
mais pour combattre la droite monsieur
marché il faut soutenir le gouvernement
michel rocard non non non ça c'est une
une vue étroite de la situation on peut
très bien sur le plan gouvernemental
avoir une vie différente sur la façon de
gérer les affaires du pays conformément
aux intérêts des travailleurs et aux
intérêts de la nation
on peut sur ce terrain avoir des
divergences mais cela n'empêche pas que
sur le terrain municipal
nous pouvons gérer ensemble d'aller en
marchant sans justement aux listes
d'ailleurs attendait renault gagne
expérience il ya une expérience depuis
bien avant 1983 ça fait quinze ans que
dans certaines villes on gère ensemble
et depuis 1983
nous gérons dans beaucoup de villes et
pourtant vous le savez bien entre nos
deux partis
eh bien il ya eu des moments et il y a
des moments difficiles il s'agit
d'élections municipales
l'objectif c'est d'empêcher la droite
oui le prendre là on l'a bien répéter
mais combien il y aura 2
rang de listes de rassemblement dont on
a parlé dans les grandes villes par
exemple partout ça nous un départ des
communistes bon à droite où la patronne
du marché il n'y aura aucune primaires
hap à deux pas du fait du parti
communiste et le parti communiste et je
le dis et redis cet après midi le parti
communiste en appliquant d'ailleurs très
fermement très résolument les d'accord
c'est à dire les engagements que nous
avons pris ensemble
selon nous il ne doit pas y avoir de
primaire est ce que par exemple on
pourra trouver des communistes monsieur
marché sur des listes menées par exemple
par jean pierre soisson jean marie
rausch s'annoncer très clair et parti
socialiste le sait nous l'avons dit nous
ne participerons pas aux listes à
auxerre a mais tu sais et éventuellement
si durafour usto les rues étaient
candidats dans une autre ville j'ai
demandé ma loge et réaliste le sait
c'est très clair il ya donc des bavures
non c'est pas des bavures pourquoi vous
appelez ça une bavure nous nous avons
toujours dit que pour ce qui nous
concerne nous ne pensons pas qu'il est
possible de faire une politique de
gauche dans les municipalités avec des
hommes de droite c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes opposés à des
alliances avec la droite
cela étant dit dernière question georges
marchais dernière question à attendait
parce que au fond l'ensemble de vos
questions ramène à essayer de minimiser
cette pas essayé mais en tout cas à
minimiser la portée de l'accord qui a
été réalisé moi je considère que
naturellement cette anbar maintenant que
tout va se régler
dès demain il faut engager la discussion
dans chaque ville dans chaque
département pour aboutir à un accord à
aboutir à un accord c'est à dire que ce
que nous voulons c'est clair nous
voulons que tous les maires communistes
concerne leur municipalité
nous voulons tous les maires socialistes
conservent leur municipalité et nous
voulons gagner ensemble
d'autres municipalités sur la droite
voilà l'objectif je crois
qu'effectivement on a bien compris
georges marchais simplement une dernière
question sans rapport et les voir il ya
eu récemment des affaires de fraude en
bourse qui concerne beaucoup les milieux
proches du pouvoir enfin on l'a dit
c'est par exemple la sphère pechiney
la sphère de la société générale vous en
avez parlé ça avec monsieur mauroy non
non on va parler de ça manson et vous
vous avez un sentiment là-dessus nous
nous sommes jour je participe à l'heure
de vérité lundi soir eh bien si on me
pose la question
j'y répondrai à quoi l'occasion de
l'heure de vérité pour ce soir il s'agit
uniquement de bien comprendre qu'un
accord a été réalisée que maintenant il
faut travailler d'arrache-pied très vite
dans chaque ville pour aboutir à une
liste dur nous avons bien compris
georges marchais merci pour la ruralité
de chasse et importante les
téléspectateurs comprennent dans l'un
des leurs intérêts dans l'intérêt des
populations
l'intérêt qu'il y à conserver les verts
communistes mais aussi les maires
socialistes et à gagner de nouvelle
mairie
merci georges marchais nous en venons
justement à la ferté chine et elle prend
de plus en plus une tournure politique
il s'agit d'une affaire de fraude en
bourse au moment du rachat d'une société
américaine par péchiney vous le savez
des personnalités politiques proches du
pouvoir sont en cause je le disais à
l'instant
cette fois les états majors politiques
s'emparent de la sphère l'opposition
aujourd'hui est monté au créneau et les
ministres ont aussitôt répondu compte
rendu de cette journée il y aura-t-il
une nouvelle enquête sur la sphère
pechiney aujourd'hui l'opposition monte
au créneau et demande que la commission
des finances de l'assemblée nationale
soit saisie de la faire les procédures
se sont poursuivies et vous souhaitons
qu'ils aillent vraiment jusqu'au bout
car la collusion entre le pouvoir
politique et le pouvoir de l'argent le
pouvoir socialiste et le pouvoir de
l'argent que cette affaire est en train
de révéler très très grave
parmi les noms cités dans la sphère
pechiney celui d'un collaborateur direct
de pierre bérégovoy
aujourd'hui le ministre s'insurge et
déclare je suis entouré de gens honnêtes
j'ai demandé à la cob d'agir avec
célérité
autrement dit d'agir vite et de
rechercher la vérité par tous les moyens
mais dans une autre affaire celle de la
société générale ou serait mêlé à la
fois la caisse des dépôts et des
banquiers proches de l'opposition
le ministre de l'industrie roger fauroux
jette un nouveau pavé dans la mare et 17
affaire aussi est très grand
grand parce qu'elle pose un problème du
rôle des institutions comme la caisse
des pouces et tout et tout le monde est
bien d'accord il faut qu'il y ait un
débat sur les bases larges revers qui
s'ouvre sur ce problème
sauf que je dis donc là cobayes jusqu'au
bout ah oui tout à fait et pourtant ce
soir la commission des opérations de
bourse réaffirme qu'elle n'enquêtera pas
sur la sphère de la société générale et
au chapitre économique que toujours
j'ajoute qu'alain chevalier président du
directoire de moët hennessy louis
vuitton lvmh comme on dit quand on est
branché
alain chevalier donc à démissionner
c'est un début de dénouement pour cette
affaire qu'il l'a encore faisait
beaucoup parlé à la bourse
après plus de vingt mois d'arrêt
superphénix va fonctionner de nouveau le
ministre de l'industrie vient de donner
son autorisation pour que redémarre ce
réacteurs surgénérateurs construisent
sur le rhône a créé smallville on avait
beaucoup parlé au moment de son arrêt en
mars 87 à l'époque on avait découvert
une fuite et tout le monde s'était
alarmé patrick hester après 20 mois
d'arrêt les techniciens d'edf vont donc
pouvoir remettre en service le réacteur
de superphénix
les autorités de sûreté ont donc donné
officiellement leur feu vert ce matin du
mois à titre provisoire jusqu'au 1er
septembre 89
depuis la découverte en avril 87 d'une
fissure de 60 cm dans le métal de la cus
du baril et de chargement en combustible
les techniciens du nucléaire ont dû
répondre à plusieurs questions
le réacteur peut-il en toute sécurité
fonctionner sans ce système le métal de
la cuve du réacteur lui-même
n'est-il pas atteint de la même maladie
et surtout comment faire face à une
fuite éventuelle sur ce réacteur
aujourd'hui les autorités de sûreté
pense que ces points sont réglés
les autorités helvétiques ont été
informés de la décision prise
mais du côté des écologistes français et
suisses les protestations commencent à
gronder
le gouvernement se remet à t-il à dieu
pour assurer la sécurité du
surgénérateur il fait démarrer une
chaudière atomique sans l'une des pièces
essentielles de sa sécurité
c'est à dire le barillet qui avait été
considéré comme indispensable au moment
du démarrage initial du surgénérateur
aujourd'hui la france est avec le japon
l'un des derniers pays au monde à
s'entêter à développer du nucléaire
c'est à dire une voie que nous
considérons comme dangereuse et absurde
merveille de technologie pour les uns
machine infernale pour les autres
au-delà des problèmes techniques ou
économiques superphénix reste pour
beaucoup le symbole du risque nucléaire
une quinzaine d'interpellations dans les
milieux royalistes à paris c'est la
suite de l'agression commise vendredi
dernier au théâtre des bouffes du nord à
paris contre la chanteuse hélène
delavault et son spectacle de chansons
de la révolution voyons maintenant
d'autres informations sur les affaires
cliniques criminelle dont nous vous
avons parlé ces jours derniers pascal
deschamps la voiture du juge bernard a
bien été saboté les deux durite
d'arrivée d'essence et du liquide de
freins ont été sectionnés affirmé
aujourd'hui le procureur adjoint de
lille jean pierre bernard chargé
jusqu'au début de la semaine d'instruire
la faire quand s'en étaient venus
prendre ses nouvelles fonctions au
palais de justice de lille mercredi
et c'est lorsqu'il descendait la rampe
d'accès du parking que ses freins ont
lâché une information judiciaire a été
ouverte
les recherches se sont poursuivies
aujourd'hui en forêt de fontainebleau
pour déterminer quand et comment les
deux bus paris disparu de la toussaint
ont été tués la police scientifique
s'intéresse notamment aux deux douilles
et aux traces de pneus découverte à
proximité
les enquêteurs pensent que les corps ont
été déposés ici récemment pour preuve
l'endroit n'avait pas échappé aux
premières recherches quant au corps ils
ne présentent pas l'aspect de
décomposition qu'il devrait avoir un
très fluide de deux mois en plein air
les résultats de l'autopsié seront
connus à la fin de la semaine
m
la quatrième journée du procès d'action
directe a été consacrée à l'audition des
derniers témoins devant un box vive
amené au palais de justice aubron
ménigon rouillan cipriani ont préféré
aujourd'hui encore rester dans la salle
d'attentes des accusés où ils peuvent
parler librement ensemble leurs avocats
qui refusent depuis le début de la
semaine de discuter des faits eux mêmes
étaient là les sont restés muets se
réservant pour leurs plaidoiries prévues
samedi
le verdict sera connu en fin de soirée
hier soir le président reagan a dit
adieu au peuple américain neuf jours
avant son départ officiel de la maison
blanche ronald reagan a tenu à avoir une
dernière conversation avec le peuple
américain
écoutez le ton de leur conversation
huit ans de présidence qui se termine
pour ronald reagan lorsqu'il achèvera
son mandat le 20 janvier il les fera une
image forte dans l'histoire de son pays
qui l'eût cru il ya seulement huit ans à
l'époque ronald reagan n'était qu'un
acteur qui avait réussi dans la
politique mais au fond l'image de
l'acteur l'at-elle quitter on ne s'en
sépare pas si facilement lorsqu'on a
tourné 50 films à hollywood
même si ces films comme sont deux
victoires la loi et l'ordre ou encore la
fille de jeunes beach même si ces films
ne sont pas vraiment des chefs-d'oeuvre
paul nahon et alexandre guinhut et se
sont livrés un savant montage les gestes
de reggane président et les gestes de
reggane acteurs d'hollywood
regardez cet époustouflant
qui a réellement gouverner l'acteur où
le président ronald reagan a déjà
répondu à cette question les deux à la
fois
ronald reagan qui demandait souvent en
public mais comment quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais été acteur peut-il devenir
président ronald reagan va quitter la
scène celui dont on affirme déjà que
c'est le plus grand président depuis
roosevelt d'hollywood à la comédie du
pouvoir il n'y avait presque qu'un pas
il a joué à la maison blanche son
meilleur rôle avec à ses côtés sa
partenaire préféré nancy sa deuxième
femme rencontrée sur un tournage
cinquante films où il a incarné le mythe
du héros américain
l'aventurier des temps modernes
principales qualités de l'acteur écouter
principales qualités du président
écoutez
il a utilisé le fait d'être un acteur
professionnel pour se constituer de un
rôle politique
c'est très important il a réussi à
merveille regan qui a commencé par être
commentateur de baseball à la radio et
ensuite il a un carnet d'aventurier il a
il a incarné des rôles un peu un peu
fabuleux et de là il est passé au
président ce qui représente espèce de
mythe de la réussite l'a beaucoup
d'attrait pour les américains au pouvoir
comme dans ses films il a su employer
les mots simples le bien le mal
des mots qui sont allé tout droit au
coeur de ses concitoyens
l'ancien premier ministre japonais n'a
qu'a sonné affirmé j'admire et gagnent
parce qu'il ressemble à john wayne
en tout cas jamais un président n'aura
quitté la maison blanche avec une telle
popularité popularité à son zénith après
l'attentât dont il a été victime il lui
aura fallu seulement une semaine pour
récupérer
sur l'album photo de ses huit ans sans
doute son plus beau souvenir
le grand communicateur aura même réussi
à faire oublier qu'il est le premier
président divorcer dans toute l'histoire
des états unis
sa femme nancy a joué un rôle capital
deux conseillères en fait sa seule
confidente
le film se termine avec une fin heureuse
comme à hollywood où les reggane vont
retourner mais seule l'histoire dira si
l'acteur a été bon président
etonnant non cette décision des
autorités de moscou le nagorny karabakh
qui était réclamée par l'arménie restera
à l'azerbaïdjan
mais et c'est important il aura une
administration particulière cela veut
dire que moscou surveillera tout cela de
près d'autres informations
internationales de ce mercredi
en bref en images véronique saint olive
signature à alger en début d'après midi
un accord commercial sur le grave entre
la france et l'algérie
l'aboutissement de deux ans de
négociations entre gaz de france et la
sonatrach algérienne
le prix convenu n'est pas encore connue
mais l'accord serait applicable de 85 à
les chasseurs israéliens volant à basse
altitude ont bombardé pour la deuxième
fois en 24 heures les positions
palestiniennes au sud liban
laura leur aide aujourd'hui était
dirigée contre une base du fatah le
conseil révolutionnaire d'abou nidal
quatre personnes ont été blessées au
cours de ces attaques
ce lieu autres moeurs la députée
israélienne giulani fall honni et le
représentant de l'ol fait ibrahim sousse
se parle c'est être au sénat tout à
l'heure au cours du colloque organisé
par l'association initiative pour la
paix au proche orient
la présence des quatre députés
israéliens fait scandale en israël une
loi leur interdit de rencontrer des
membres de l'oaci
la brigade franco-allemande existe la
preuve l'inspecteur général de l'armée
de terre ouest allemande a annoncé la
première manoeuvre pour la fin de
l'année 90 helmut kohl et françois
mitterrand avait souhaité en 87 la
création de cette brigade son
commandement sera alternée reste à
résoudre deux problèmes détail une forme
et la coupe de cheveux cette devise que
j'aime bien on finit toujours par tomber
du côté où l'on penche une devise que
l'on pourrait appliquer aux boxeurs jean
claude fontana surveillée depuis un an
les policiers ont fini par l'arrêter
pour trafic de drogue
c'était un boxeur toulonnais d'une bonne
valeur internationale en quête de
patrice blais chaos judiciaire pour jean
claude fontana sur la route des
championnats du monde
un palmarès de gagnant pour ce poids
welters 20 combats autant de victoires
mais aujourd'hui la justice se mêle de
sa carrière accusations convergentes de
cinq inculpés fontana aurait été leur
principal fournisseur de cocaïne au club
de la seyne sur mer c'est la
stupéfaction
jean petit garçon toujours le sourire
toujours serviable
c'était un peu le chouchou même du ring
c'est noir jean-claude n'a jamais eu une
attitude qui lie ces supposés
quelque chose aux questions physiquement
il y avait foule hier souhaiter voir une
très bien et haïti est alors drogué
fontana n'aurait jamais mené sa carrière
la célébrité en revanche lui aura
peut-être attiré de mauvais ami dans le
dossier pas de preuves flagrantes
filature et perquisitions n'ont rien
donné ce sont nos militants sionistes
dans un certain sens ça répond aux
nécessités de l'enquète sur le plan
proprement juridique de la session la
vérité dans ce dossier
évidemment les deux sont provisoires
n'est pas du tout nécessaire ils garent
à la personnalité monsieur fontana et à
sang aux charges qui pèsent contre eux
dans ce dossier pas de confrontation
avec les autres inculpés de cette
affaire avant début février le
britannique guérite jacobs sera sans
adversaire le 25 janvier prochain
en sport résultats de ski la descente
féminine de greendale valdes a été gagné
par la suissesse michelle a figé ni vous
la voyez c'est la championne olympique
de la spécialité bonnes performances
d'une française c'est carole merle à la
boîte si elle a terminé troisième grâce
à sa troisième place car olmert s'est
hissé à la troisième place de la coupe
du monde justement
les jeux olympiques sous le signe d' à 2
ou à 12 sous le signe des jeux
olympiques c'est comme vous voulez en
tout cas pour les jeux d'albertville ce
sera antenne 2 avec fr3 c'est à dire
tout le service public de la télévision
qui vous retransmettra ces jeux une
garantie de qualité et de passion bien
sûr jean ma mère albertville et sa
mairie seront donc en 92 et pour quinze
jours le centre mondial du ski pour
antenne 2 fr3 et france inter l'ensemble
du service public ces jeux olympiques
d'hiver sont en grands défis de la
communication a relevé avec france
télécom et la collaboration de tdf et de
la sfp ce sont 23 cars régie 156 caméra
300 magnétoscope 550 cabine de
commentateur utilisé sans oublier le
centre de presse ultra moderne de
moutier capable d'accueillir 12 cents
personnes l'utilisation du satellite
bien sûr et de la fibre optique pour
courchevel méribel permettront ainsi une
couverture complète et totale à
destination du monde entier et sur les
procédés les plus modernes et notamment
sur la manière de mélanger les îles ce
seront des installations hyper
sophistiqué et totalement neuves qui
seront mises en place même le choix des
douze sites olympiques a été fait le
plus souvent en fonction du spectacle
télévisuel exemple la descente de val
d'isère
un nouveau tracé lui a été dessinée
destinée à recevoir 25 caméras une tous
les 100 mètres sans ne rien coûter à son
côté purement sportif
ce fan de sang éminemment technique
spectaculaire qui sera vue de
du pied des pistes sur pratiquement sa
totalité ce qui n'arrive jamais la
descente femmes de méribel est de la
même veine et donc là encore on se
dirige vers des décisions qui ont déjà
des prises qui ont été difficile à
prendre parce qu'elles sont risquées
mais qui doivent nous amener à présenter
un programme et pour les images
télévision et cinéma et pour les
spectateurs qui sera une habituelle al
belleville les jeux d'albertville risque
bien dans ces conditions d'être alors
une belle fête
il y avait un tiercé quarté + voici les
résultats c'était à cagnes-sur-mer je
vous le rappelle lors de l'arrivée du
tiercé 7 18 17 295 francs dans l'ordre
59 rentrer dans les ordres c'est un
petit tiercé le quarté fait 18 17 on
ajoute le 12
un quarter pas très gros non plus 1962
francs dans l'ordre 163 150 dans le
désordre
voilà dans un instant la météo de
laurent cabrol qui aperçoit pour demain
quelques rayons de soleil lui il peut
faire ça le prochain rendez vous avec
l'information c'est henri sannier à
22h30 avec un flash et puis à minuit
pour la dernière édition du journal
juste après édition spéciale consacrée
aux armes chimiques
demain 6h45 télématin roger zabel et
toute sa troupe l'invité des 4 vérités
ce sera le directeur du bate et le
bureau international du travail
francis blanchard à demain soir 20h